[Musik]
was wir heute noch können was wir morgen
nicht mehr können
so lautet das motto der diesjährigen
leistungsschau des bundesheeres am
nationalfeiertag in wien im vergleich zu
den letzten jahren also nicht nur eine
präsentation der fähigkeiten unserer
soldaten sondern auch ein appell an die
bevölkerung für viele ernüchtern
doch die budgetäre not und der daraus
resultierende zustand des heeres soll
nicht verschwiegen werden
der dialog mit der bevölkerung ist mir
sehr wichtig vor allem war das ein grund
warum wir uns entschieden haben trotz
der sparzwänge diesen nationalfeiertag
in der waadt durchzuführen ja wir haben
einen juni zu einer meinungsumfrage
gehabt wo sie über 60 prozent der
österreicherinnen und österreich im
sattel des bund selber geld in der
zwischenzeit sind es über 80 prozent und
wien überzeugt nach dem heutigen tag
wird es noch ein paar prozentpunkte mehr
sein
und das hat natürlich auswirkungen auch
auf die politischen verantwortungsträger
und das künftige regierungsprogramm
es heißt also hoffen auf eine baldige
finanzspritze
die motivation und kompetenz unserer
soldaten stellt hier jedenfalls kaum
jemand in frage
selbstbewusst präsentiert sich das
bundesheer an verschiedenen stationen
und gibt den besuchern einen einblick in
dessen fähigkeiten die themenbereiche
umfassenden schutz kritischer
infrastruktur schutz der bevölkerung
auslandseinsätze und hilfe bei
katastrophen an traditionellen
ereignissen wie der kranzniederlegung
durch den bundespräsidenten und die
bundesregierung oder der angelobung
ändert sich jedenfalls nichts mehr als
1000 soldaten legen auch heuer vor
zahlreichen zuschauern ihr treiben die
louis ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]